it has been many months since the mass
shooting in Las Vegas the largest in
modern American history even now new
information for some reason continues to
trickle out key information newly
released video shows Las Vegas police
waiting in the hallway at the Mandalay
Bay Hotel even as Steven paddock
continues to murder people below the
obvious question is why is this footage
coming out now and why did the police
not act for several minutes
Katherine Lombardo is an attorney
representing some of the victims of
those shootings and she joins us tonight
Catherine thank you for coming on so the
first question is why are we finding
this out now this seems like a central
piece of information in this story
because the court ordered the Las Vegas
Metro Police Department to release all
of this video footage and pursuant to
court order they are releasing it piece
by piece over the last couple of months
and as you know yesterday we received
about a dozen videos and many more audio
videos showing mostly police officer
body worn camera footage it's
fascinating it is also very very
upsetting
it shows the extremeness of the event
and the trauma that everyone there the
22,000 people who are there have
suffered you know interesting in that
video I've been in that very hallway in
the stairwell at the door there on the
31st floor and the 32nd floor I was
there just some months ago and what the
video clearly shows is that this one
particular police officer was on the
31st floor not the 32nd floor and he was
there for many many moments what we find
interesting is that the Mandalay Bay
security officer who was with that
particular police officer before the
shooting started and raced through the
casino floor and raced up the elevators
with him this particular Mandalay Bay
security guard said
that he was on the 32nd floor with that
particular officer in the video on the
31st floor this Mandalay Bay security
manager told the FBI on nine separate
occasions in his interviews that he was
certain he was with this officer
Hendricks on the 32nd floor
so we already knew that this officer
Hendricks was on the 31st floor but it
wasn't until yesterday when all of that
video was released that we finally got
confirmation that something is wrong
something's amiss this whole thing it's
just the tip of the iceberg we've only
scratched the surface it's unbelievable
it's the second time in several months
we've seen armed police officers stand
there while a mass murder takes but I'm
very sympathetic to cops I think take a
lot of crap but I think we deserve an
explanation for why this keeps her Mike
thank you one less than thought on that
I have a client whose spouse was shot
and killed inside the venue during the
12th and final burst of gunfire and I
just want to put that out there because
had they been in right well I mean can
you imagine unfortunately out of time
but but I hope our hope our audience
thinks about that how would you like
that was your Emmy thank you yeah
meditate on that format Catherine thank
you